- And a couple of weeks ago
during our singles awareness week,
I was honored to catch up
with the lovely Al Roker,
I love him so much.
And we both like to talk,
so, we talked a lot,
and not all of it could
fit into that show.
So today I present to you a Kelly extra,
footage we've never shown before,
here's Al and me nerding
out about being nerds.
Well, like I said earlier
it Singles Awareness Week
and you've been married
to Deborah for 25 year
which is amazing.
But what are you like as a single guy?
- I was pretty pathetic.
(audience laughs)
Look, I'm comic book guy (laughs) -
- That's not pathetic.
- Well, but you don't see
a lot of comic book guys
with dates.
And I know that maybe generalization.
Look, in high school,
I was on the AV squad.
There weren't a lot of
high school girls who said,
"You know what? I wanna date a guy
who can thread a projector,"
it just wasn't happening.
- My first job was at a movie theater,
and I always wanted to work projection.
There were only guys up there,
and they got to thread the film,
and I thought it was cool
to be able to splice film
or whatever, so I worked my way in there.
I did, I wasn't supposed
to, sorry district manager,
but I'm telling you now I did.
And, I went up there and I
got to splice it together
and I found that really interesting.
But, this is coming from a person that
plays Scrabble, and reads books,
and does things (laughs) that
maybe aren't super exciting.
- I do the same. Scrabble,
growing up Scrabble
very big in our household.
- Me too.
- In fact, my mother...
You couldn't make letters
less than three letter,
you could make words with
less than three letters,
that was her-
- My mother, she hates it
when you use QI like chi,
she gets so mad at my
sister and she's like,
"Oh if you're gonna cheat,"
she gets so mad about it (laughs) .
But anyway, I love.
And I actually learned how
to spell with my mother
using Scrabble.
She was a huge person into that as well,
and reading she's an avid reader.
But, anyway I was kinda nerdy
too, but here's my thing,
there are nerds out there,
so, we just date nerds.
- Yeah.
- We had common interests.
But, tell me about one of
your first dates though
with Deborah. What was that like?
- You know, it was funny,
we were in that "friendzone,"
we were friends,
and she said, "Oh, let's
not ruin that friendship."
And she had gone out,
she was covering an event
for a couple of weeks,
and asked me to keep an
eye on her apartment.
So I did, and I had to snoop around.
I was in the kitchen,
and I opened up the fridge,
and there's nothing...
She's in the background
right now yelling about this.
(all laugh)
There's nothing in the fridge,
like some old cheese, a
bottle of Grey Poupon mustard,
that's about it.
I open up the oven
expecting to see a mess,
she still had...
It was a new oven I guess
when she had moved in,
the cardboard was still
on the oven grates.
I thought, "This woman's
never used this oven,"
what is this? This is insane.
So, a day before she
got back from her trip,
I stocked her pantry, I
stocked her refrigerator,
and left some flowers on the table,
and a note, "Welcome home."
And then I got my first
date with her a week later.
- I'm like, "That's a nice entrance sir."
If I come home to my...
I wasn't far from Deborah by the way.
And by the way you add
some wine to that cheese,
little grape fruit and some crackers,
it's a nice charcuterie board, whatever.
It's fine, it's a meal for some people Al.
But that's awesome, that was smooth.
You're smooth.
You're a nerd, but smooth
nerd, I'm just saying.
So, how do you guys...
This is a real question,
how do you guys handle
disagreements as a couple?
Because, it happens even
when you love each other
you disagree on big and small things.
So how have y'all...
25 years, you're nailing
it, so how are you doing it?
- Well, the reason I'm nailing
it is because of Deborah.
Because, the fact is I pout, I kinda sulk,
and finally, "What's wrong?"
I'm like "nothing's wrong, I'm fine,"
and then she draws it
out of me and we talk.
And eventually we do talk it out,
but I'm very sensitive.
Deborah's mom had a saying,
"Your feelings are as light as a feather."
And I'm very thin-skinned,
I'm a bit of a baby.
- I guess then what you're saying is
yin and yang really does
work in a relationship.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah.
- It's funny because the kids know,
like Leila our middle girl will
say, "Mom, give dad a break,
he has so little to live for."
(all laugh)
- Oh my God (laughs) !
(laughing) That's like what just happened?
I need to have a talk with
her about feelings (laughs) ,
and the fact that you have them (laughs) .
I literally will look at my...
My kids man, they could be so mean,
and I will look at my
daughter straight in the face
and I'm like, "Are you
serious? I'm about to cry.
That's mean"
(audience applaud)
- Catch Al Roker every morning
on the "Today" show on NBC.